-My first guest
is a nine-time Emmy nominated
actor and producer
starring on the seventh season
of "Black-ish,"
which airs Wednesdays
at 9:30 p.m. on ABC.
Here is Anthony Anderson!
Yeah! That --
-Whoo-whoo! Yeah-yeah!
-Yeah, the neat-looking.
You look good, buddy.
I love it.
-Thank you, baby.
-You look great, man.
Thanks for coming back
on the show.
Hey, how was your
Halloween weekend?
Did you celebrate Halloween?
-No, I did not celebrate it,
man.
You know, our kids
are 24 and 20 now,
and they're out of the house.
So there was really no need
for us to celebrate Halloween.
But my wife wanted to decorate.
And I was like,
"Okay, that's cool."
But she decorated the house,
man, inside and out
as if we were having kids
come up to the door.
And I was like, I don't want
these little COVID babies
running up to our door,
ringing the doorbell,
trying to get candy.
-Yeah. I want no people
to come here.
-No, we normally do it big on
Halloween in our neighborhood,
but, you know, no one did.
But she decorated
the inside of the house
like it was
a Halloween festival, man.
And it's just her, myself,
and our blind dog Riley
just walking around bumping into
pumpkins and candy stashes.
And I'm a type 2 diabetic,
Jimmy.
So I don't know why
she's tempting me
with all this damn candy
in the house.
-Oh, my gosh.
I want to talk to you --
Last time I talked to you,
you were planning on
all these big summer
celebrations
you were looking forward to,
but with quarantine,
you can't really do that.
I mean, you were
going to get your star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame,
and you were going to turn 50.
-I did.
Those things still happened.
They just didn't happen
like we wanted them to.
There was no pomp
and circumstance
for the star
on the Walk of Fame.
I had 11 people there --
8 family members,
my manager who spoke,
my agent, and George Lopez,
who spoke at --
and my mom, who spoke, as well.
Oh, I would be remiss
if I didn't show you this.
Let me see -- Can you see that?
-Yeah.
-It's my Hollywood
Walk of Fame ring...
-Wow.
-...that George Lopez
and Ced the Entertainer
got for me.
-Holy moly. That's a nice ring.
Wait. Why do they -- Why -- Just
'cause they're your friends?
-Yeah, well, George Lopez got
his star on the Walk of Fame.
He was the first one
of our whole crew.
So he bought the ring
for himself.
Cedric the Entertainer was the
next one of our crew who got it,
so he bought Ced a ring.
I was the third in our crew,
so George and Ced
put in and got the ring.
And our crew is me, George,
Ced, D.L. Hughley,
Don Cheadle, and Chris Spencer.
So, the next person who --
who I believe is Don
who's next in line,
we'll all pitch in
and get him his Hollywood
Walk of Fame ring, as well.
-I saw a fun video that
you posted of you and your son
celebrating your star
on the Walk of Fame.
Let's take a look at
a little bit of that right here.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Come on, dude.
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on, dude.
-I don't think
that's the song that was playing
when we were dancing
on the strip, there, Jimmy.
-We couldn't clear that song.
-No, I understand. I understand.
I just want the world to know
that's not what was playing
from the car.
[ Both laugh ]
-We can't afford that, man.
Come on.
That's a dream come true, man.
That's pretty cool.
You have a star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Yeah, man, it is.
And I went to Hollywood High,
literally across the street
from where my star is.
And never in a thousand years
did I ever think
walking those streets
that I would be immortalized
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Oh, congrats.
-And I want
to throw this in there.
My mother has vowed to come
out there with her assistant
once a month to clean my star.
Mama, November 5th
is your month.
Come up. It's your day
of the month,
November 5th.
-Oh, my God. Do not --
-The 5th of every month,
she has to come out.
-No, do not make your mom
clean your -- Absolutely not.
No, no. You're a big boy.
-She offered it, Jimmy!
She offered it!
-You're a big boy now.
You don't do that. Come on, man.
You're 50.
-Yeah.
-That's amazing.
You look fantastic.
50 years old.
-Thank you, babe. Well, you know
black don't crack.
It does chip
a little bit, though,
and it starts to rot
on the inside.
-Wait, I have to talk
about this.
You did something
very big recently,
I think like around
two weeks ago
that was --
-Oh.
[ Laughs ]
-I have to talk about it.
Can we?
-Yeah, let's talk about it.
You know what? I went and had --
Because I turned 50, I went
and had a colonoscopy done.
It was that time.
-Yeah.
-You know, I had been getting
the PSA, the blood test done
up until then. But turning 50 --
And I should actually had this
procedure done when I was 45,
so I'm a little late
to the game.
But I wanted to document it
to take the stigma
off of getting a colonoscopy,
especially for men of color, to
go in and get this checked out,
because it's better --
-What is it like?
What do you do?
What is it like?
-You know what, man?
They give you --
You change your diet
four to five days before,
and it's a low-fiber diet
for obvious reasons.
-Yeah.
-The prep day
is the most difficult day,
and difficult is the only word
that I can use
be-- It's not that bad.
You have to flush yourself out.
They give you
a solution to drink.
You can't eat any solid foods.
And you go into the doctor's
office the next day,
they give you
the Michael Jackson,
you lay it out
for an hour and a half,
and you don't feel anything
before, during, or after.
-You don't.
And so you're back up,
and you're like,
everything went well?
-It was best hour and a half
nap, sleep that I had.
The procedure
only took 15 minutes.
And as I posted
on my social media pages,
I had a clean bill of health.
-[ Clapping ]
-You know, there were no polyps.
There was nothing there.
So I did that so I could get
men, especially men of color,
to go into their doctor's office
and get a colonoscopy done.
It's better
to have it done early
and understand what it is
that you need done
if you need something done
than wait till the last minute,
and the outcome
won't be so great.
-It's great that you did that,
and it's great
that you're using your platform
to raise awareness.
There's a lot more
to talk about.
Can you stick around
for a little longer?
-I have nowhere to go, Jimmy.
-More with Anthony Anderson
when we come back.